hi everyone sal khan here from khan
academy welcome to our homeroom live
stream we have a very exciting guest
rohima ellis who is the education
correspondent for the nbc nightly news
but before we get into that what
promises to be very exciting
conversation i'll give my standard
announcements one a reminder that we are
a not-for-profit and we can only exist
through philanthropic donations from
folks like yourself so if you're in a
position to do so please think about
going to khan academy.org
donate also want to make a shout out to
several organizations that have stepped
up to help khan academy especially
during the covid school closure what can
only be described as a crisis
where khan academy's traffic has gone up
dramatically our costs have gone up so
special thanks to bank of america
google.org at t fastly end of artists to
help close that gap but we also need
more especially as we go into 2021.
last reminder there is a version of this
live stream in podcast form
homeroom with sal the podcast get that
wherever you get your podcasts so with
that i'm excited to welcome rehema ellis
to our conversation today
rehema good to see you
nice to see you so
there's so much i want to talk to you
about but the two things i think will be
really interesting and i encourage
everyone
listening or seeing this on youtube and
facebook to ask questions especially in
these two dimensions but really on
anything
you you're the education correspondent
so you're really
seeing on the ground what's happening in
school so i encourage people ask
questions about that but also just your
life journey uh as a very successful
journalist any questions people have on
that as well but maybe a good place to
start is just where where are we you
know what are you seeing i know nbc
nightly news is going to be doing a
whole series on understanding how
teachers are adapting to kovid
what are what has been some of your
biggest takeaways so far
one of the things that is my big
takeaway is i hope that people will gain
a greater appreciation respect and
recognition if you will of teachers as
all parents and i'm a parent myself find
ourselves at home with our children we
love them dearly and care for them
dearly but some of us are not the best
teachers for the ones that we love and
we're seeing a tremendous amount of
appreciation for what teachers do we
care for our children because we love
them but we entrust them to a stranger
to care for some 25 sometimes 30
children in a classroom and for those
who do it with such magnificence and
such passion and concern
they are really superstars in terms of
our children's lives and ultimately in
terms of the life of our society because
a society to prosper requires demands
really an educated population so that's
one of the things that i'm seeing i'm
hearing a lot of people talking about
geez i had no idea how hard it is to be
an educator
absolutely it's funny when you were
saying
when you kind of reminded yourself i
love my children dearly um i think you
you expressed what a lot of parents
expressed but especially during covid
where we remind ourselves that we love
our children dearly but maybe my my
children were a little bit harder to
deal with on a full day basis than
originally expected
for an untrained you know a parent who
is not trained as an educator you start
to see this is really challenging and so
this appreciation i think is wonderful
and i'm so happy to be a part of what
nbc nightly news is doing and that is
devoting a whole week to what we call
teacher appreciation to really
highlighting some of these superstars in
the field of education and there are a
lot of them
and and it might be obvious but you know
and this nbc's credit nbc has always
kind of put a real emphasis on education
what has been what was the catalyst for
doing this focus a whole week on not
just teacher appreciation but how
teachers are navigating the crisis
well one of the things is the crisis
that we are in it's not just something
that's outside of the classrooms even
our children are not in the classrooms
it's not just something that's not
happening to children it is happening to
children even though children are not
among those whose numbers are seen as
the fatalities of this dreaded virus but
children are being severely impacted by
it not being in school a place that's a
social environment it's a learning
environment it's an opportunity to
learn how to not just
learn your abcs but how to communicate
in a community
when we don't have that that's really
damaging is really impactful on children
nbc
recognizes that and said let's take a
minute to see
what teachers are doing to try and fill
that very important and large gap that's
occurring for so many of our children as
they're learning remotely
and you know i i want to get into some
of what y'all will cover uh but there's
a question from youtube mr spector asks
uh miss alice is it hard finding stories
and that's actually interesting because
this is kind of the intersection of the
two things i want to talk about when you
all decide that you want to do let's say
a week of reporting on teaching
especially the crisis what's the process
for y'all how do y'all find out the
interesting stories and and how do you
uh kind of surface the the real human
element of it
it is varied it's um sometimes it's
complicated and sometimes it's easy
sometimes we'll see what our colleagues
have done on other platforms be it
newspaper of the television programs etc
and we'll say oh my gosh that's a great
story if we're looking from local
television programs we'll have a
producer a camera person a correspondent
like myself in a particular city and say
i saw this story on local television
this would be the kind of story that we
should tell our viewers all around the
country and indeed all around the world
and then we sometimes just call up
schools scholar call of school
departments call up local um community
agencies and ask them
what's going on in your community that
might be of interest to our viewers from
coast to coast so again it's a
complicated sometimes and the process
varies in terms of how we zero in on
stories
and and what are some of the stories you
know not to give away your whole week of
reporting but i'm assuming you've
already started to record some of them
are there any that have really stood out
to you
well of course mine stands out to me but
they all stand out to me we had one on
the air just last night about a teacher
in wisconsin who was so concerned about
the fact that she wasn't able to be with
her children because everything was shut
down was being done remotely and so she
decided that she was going to infuse
some of the sense of architectural
skills that she didn't have at least she
didn't know she had but she found out
that she did and on her classroom on her
school grounds she built a tent
with the tarp
um the um the seats the the the desk the
chairs the chalkboard books and brought
her classroom
from home everybody was at home now
they're in this classroom outside it was
so successful the whole school
now has their classrooms outside so
there's ventilation there's separation
because they have a big property that
kind of thing doesn't work so much in
the inner city but it worked wonderfully
for this school and in wisconsin and
kudos for that teacher for saying i'm
going to try something that i never
thought of before that's exactly what's
happening with the story that i'm going
to have on tomorrow it's about a science
teacher in washington dc his name is
jonte lee
and you can see from some of the
pictures he's concocted this arrangement
inside his own home
because he said to himself we got a
problem here in need of a solution
and as a science teacher he said what
can i do listen to a little clip of uh
our story
chemistry and physics is hard to do when
you're face to face how did you imagine
you would continue teaching remotely
well as you can see that i turned my
kitchen into
my classroom and that my kitchen also
became my lab
the only way that i was able to think
think of doing it successfully was to
make it as interactive as possible and
uh what better way to teach chemistry
than from the kitchen and because we do
kitchen every single day you know we do
chemistry every every single day and on
side of our kitchen it's heat um acid
bases
he's now become known as the kitchen
chemist because what this teacher did he
went above and beyond
he decided that if i'm going to have lab
experiments my students need to have lab
supplies so taking money out of his own
pocket he went and bought the supplies
and then delivered them personally to
each one of his 35 students and in so
doing he's putting up these videos these
videos have gone viral not only around
the country but around the world people
are tuning in to mr lee's classes and i
said to him
i didn't even think that students would
want to do that he's got perfect
attendance with his 35 students every
single day once again i think a
testament to a teacher who cares so much
about his kids
that he said i'm going to figure out a
way to continue to connect with him even
if it's remotely and he has a good time
doing it lots of fun
well i mean that's a fascinating story
and you know my selfishly my khan
academy hat we're actually doing a big
push in middle school and high school
chemistry and i think you might have
identified someone that we have to call
up to help us out
in fact saul he's already connected he
goes to khan academy for some of his
advice and some suggestions and ideas
that can help him with his kids so you
two already linked
well yeah i mean it's great if he can
leverage us but i think we might need to
leverage him so
that's a that's a separate that's a
separate thread that we'll take on uh so
a ton of a ton of questions are coming
out
and a lot of it about you know your life
and your life journey so before i get
into some of these questions
you know i am always fascinated by
hearing the story you know i think a lot
of kids if when they're 10 years old or
15 years old they say i want to become
a journalist or i want to you know be on
nbc nightly news uh or
you know your parents will be like all
right maybe you know your your parents
are kind of thinking about the
probabilities in your head it's like
well done why don't you just go you know
do something that you know go be an
engineer go be a doctor or lawyer or
something like that school teacher where
there where there's a clear pathway
did you always know
that you were going to be a journalist
especially a journalist on tv and and
how did you get to where you are
i absolutely did not know that i was
going to be a broadcast journalist
it was
not until my sophomore year of college
that i had a professor
and her name is andrea rushing
and she looked at a paper that i wrote
about james baldwin and she said to me
i was a sociology major she said the
conclusion you came to in the paper was
not exactly right but the way you
came to that conclusion and wrote about
it was brilliant
i respected this teacher so much also an
african-american woman that it changed
me at that point because she said i
would encourage you to be a writer i was
just blown away and i think it's one of
those things about the real value and
the poor importance and significance
that a teacher can have in someone's
life we're even profiling such a teacher
also on nightly news this week a young
man who was growing up in a shelter and
he had a fourth grade teacher who kept
telling him you can be anything that you
want to be he's now paying it forward
and he's a fifth grade teacher so
teachers are outrageously important in a
young person's life so in my sophomore
year of college i was inspired to take
some journalism courses i did not know
what i would do with them but i took the
journalism courses i then uh took had
internships which are so valuable i did
um i had a college radio station i was
the host and the producer and the anchor
of this college radio station i was
doing public affairs programming and
then i um also wrote for my local
newspaper
and then i went away i went to east
africa for a couple of years because i
wasn't quite sure that journalism was
the thing that i wanted to do
and
i came back after i got accepted to
columbia university graduate school of
journalism
and that then launched me into doing
radio and from radio i did television
and in television i ended up in new york
here with nbc
um
not what i had planned
but i am enormously grateful for where
my journey has taken me and all because
of a teacher who inspired me
you know that has a lot of uh parallels
to lester holt lester holt was on on on
this show i i always feel embarrassed
calling people who do real shows calling
this a show but uh and you know he was
talking about being kind of this radio
geek even when he was very young he
would pretend to like
do a radio show even when no one was
listening and eventually did so it
sounds like radio is a really
interesting path you know just before i
get to some of other folks questions
what do you think allowed you to really
stand out what are the skills that you
think you and i i know it's an awkward
answer to a question to answer but what
are the things that you think have
really stood out and allowed you to to
get to where you are
i actually think time is everything
timing is everything
the time that i had with that professor
in college
um having the time to have radio uh
stations who looked at me and said we
will let you do this um
then getting accepted to a great school
and from that great school i got a
scholarship and the scholarship
um it was with what was called
westinghouse broadcasting back then and
they wanted to i think cash in on their
investment they gave me some money and
they wanted to see if they could follow
through on it and i ended up in
pittsburgh pennsylvania
during radio and then to television i
had a fantastic mentor
who
saw something in me
and
encouraged me
to do things that i quite honestly
unlike lester and imagining myself doing
radio i hadn't imagined myself doing it
um
but having an opportunity to write
and in radio i loved doing radio one of
the strengths of it is you have to
create images with your words people
can't see
but they can hear
so all the sounds the sound of my voice
the sound of the voices of the people
whom i interviewed the sounds in the in
the neighborhood or the streets or the
places where i went using all of those
sounds to craft a story it was
fascinating to me
and i again i think some of it is luck
some of it is being in the right place
at the right time some of it is having
people who encourage you
to
go on and do things that sometimes you
don't even imagine that you can do
um
and then also i must say
having the parents that i had
who just always told me that once i put
my mind to something i could do it
and so i've always followed that it just
keeps me going forward
were there any moments where you've kind
of doubted yourself or you felt like hey
maybe i'm not cut out for this or i'm
not going to be able to make the dent
that i want to have
not really but the moment that i felt
when i was first starting in the
business is that all of the monumental
stories had already been told vietnam
had happened the civil rights movement
had happened
um pearl harbor had happened um so what
was i going to do a kid coming up in the
80s going into the business and i
thought my life was
pretty good actually
and the world around me was opening up
and opportunities for people who looked
like me
were beginning to open up and so what
would the stories be that i could
possibly tell
boy was i wrong and there has just been
one story after another and here we are
now in the middle of a historic moment
in terms of a pandemic i couldn't have
imagined it and i don't think that
anybody else could have either but the
minute you think that there's not a
monumental story to tell
life changes
and it can be your story
absolutely
you know there's a couple questions here
about i'll ask both of them and we can
kind of merge them from youtube
smartbear says how do you include your
nbc life with your kids i'm assuming
they're asking about kind of work-life
balance and also from youtube nish786 is
asking what are some things that you
notice now in your life after becoming a
journalist that you didn't notice before
so generally speaking
you know life work balance is a struggle
for everyone i can imagine you travel a
lot you're on the road a lot how do you
make these balances and how has it
affected your life
one of the things that happened when my
child my son
came home was
to be honest with you
it was a rebirth for me
i began to see
life completely differently from how i'd
seen it before
and the things that worried me didn't
worry at me anymore i was so consumed
with
trying to make certain that i gave my
child the best possible life and at the
same time i'm a single parent and so i
had to keep work i had to keep working
and i am so fortunate that i've had
wonderful people in my life
uh to work with me and to help me so
it's possible
that if the phone rings
i can get up and go to that destination
where the story is unfolding and
that's about
luck and i think it's also about
positioning yourself in your life and
asking quite honestly to reveal to you
to ask the universe to help me
do the kinds of things that i want to do
in order to balance life with my work
my work is enormously important to me
i can't imagine doing anything else i
really i really love this
job and i love my family
and people say can you have it all
sometimes you can sometimes you can't
sometimes your child needs to go to the
pediatrician and a story is breaking but
your child needs to go to the
pediatrician story pediatrician it
really isn't that much of a hard call to
make if your child needs something and i
again have been so fortunate i work for
a company that also recognizes
that i am a correspondent but i'm also a
human being
and i think that
that nbc appreciates the fact that i
will give my all
every single moment that i can
and when it's time to take my time for
my family i have to do that too that
makes me a better journalist i think it
makes all of us better at what we do
when we can have a little compassion
and understanding about
a little one who is dependent on us in
order to grow so to that first question
about how do i balance it i balance it
the best way i can but i also have help
to make it possible for me to do it
no it's a powerful idea because i think
a lot of times when people talk about
this they talk about oh you should
balance like it's a trade-off that hey
if you're going to take away from work
to become a better parent but to your
point especially when you're reporting
about humanity
that element that's going to make you a
better reporter to have that and a
better correspondent to have that aspect
of your life i couldn't i couldn't agree
with that more you know we have a
limited amount of time one thing that i
don't get the questions actually there's
a lot of questions coming in i'll save
one of
these for um for again but i am curious
your views on
uh just the state of
80s and 90s when you know the nightly
news was everything now we talk about
social media
oh it sounds like i might have clipped
off um
i would love your take on where we are a
journalism generally you know there's a
lot of talk about polarization people
living in their bubbles going on social
media getting their own version at the
same time we still have the nightly news
which is kind of the you know which
we've which we've had the three major
networks uh you know since for many many
decades how do you see all of this
evolving and how is it affected you know
how you all think about journalism
well the way i think about it is that
this is we're in this little bubble of
of infancy of
communication and
information technology is exploding
information is coming at us fast and
furious and constant
and
i often think of it and i don't mean
this to be disparaging in any way
whatsoever so please forgive me if
someone attempts to see it that way
i often think of it as of us as being
very young and almost childlike in the
fact that we are bombarded with
information it's almost like a child in
a candy store who is hungry for every
single bit of candy and sweetness that
they can find and it's all around them
and ultimately the child learns that
there has to be a diet
of candy and other things
protein other carbohydrates and
vegetables and vitamins you learned that
but at the beginning it's just an
explosion of excitement i think we're in
that explosion of excitement there's
information everywhere and i'm in the
information business so i would never be
one to say let's turn off the
information but one of the things i do
think is important is to understand and
to get a sense of media literacy to know
the difference between something that's
just exploding at you and something that
gives you context to the content and i
want all of us to become
really really literate and understanding
media question sources examine sources
and maybe go outside of our comfort zone
and look at a variety of different
things in so doing i think we'll become
better educated on how to use this
wonderful wonderful opportunity of
information that we have available to us
right at our fingertips
it makes a lot of sense and maybe just
just to close out you know one last
question getting from youtube again uh
actually another question from niche 786
uh what what's some advice that you
would give to teenagers i guess some
teenagers who might want to go down a
path to motor yours or people want to go
down any path what advice would you give
to your teenage self or to any teenage
self
read everything you can
information really is power it also
informs your thinking it informs your
writing it informs your perspective so
you have to read sometimes we get just
little tweets and think that now i'm
really informed well you might be really
excited
and maybe excited to go examine
something more in depth um one of the
things that happens and was said to me
when i started in the business is that
journalists we're kind of in a
30-minute broadcast of nightly news
we're conduit of information
we certainly do frame what people think
about but i hope that we encourage
people to say now let me decide what i
think about the information that you
have channeled for me to take a look at
and the only way we can do that you know
when you get a story um i hope that
people then will say let me read more
about this let me find out more about
that particular subject even let me find
more about these teachers who are
inspiring all of us and how we might be
able to appreciate them a little bit
more
not just on a short news clip that we
provide
but
going more exploring more i hope that
anyone who thinks about getting in this
business will become a glutton for
information and all kinds of information
that's what makes what we do powerful
and important to the people who are our
viewers or our readers
it makes a ton of sense and
rahim i want to thank you for joining
and i actually want to congratulate you
you're getting a major award the legacy
award from the national association of
black journalists uh that's already been
announced but you're going to get the
award i think in a few days but this is
just another testament to
um the importance of the work in your
career and uh thank you for for being
part of this and giving us a little bit
of wisdom
it's a pleasure thanks for having me
thank you
well everyone thanks for uh joining you
know these conversations always go
faster than i expected i could have
talked to him for a very very long time
uh but definitely check out nbc nightly
news and these stories there really are
incredible stories uh on education and
and teachers and uh you know for those
of you all are going to be future
journalists i think
you just heard a great role model to to
think about how you might chart your
career so anyway i will see you at the
next uh homeroom uh with with sal it's
going to be an ed talk tomorrow with
brooke mabry i will talk to you all then
you